[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum philosophischen
stammte aus dem alten kraftwerk in basel
schön sind sie dabei das hat doch etwas
an einem tisch gemeinsam zu sitzen und
strittig aktuelle fragen zu diskutieren
ohne dabei die zensur zu fürchten
doch geht das heute überhaupt noch oder
läuft der innerliche zensoren nicht
immer mit der bahn gefragt ob das was
ich sagen will überhaupt noch sagt bahr
ist ob nicht schon meine nächste
äußerung nicht den kopf gar den job
kosten könnte
die kanzel culture viel diskutiert
heftig bestritten
heute unser thema wef-gründer klaus
schwab ex-iwf-chef und us general david
richards der ehemalige novartis
verwaltungsratspräsident daniel vasella
ex nestlé ceo peter brabeck
die liste von rednern deren auftritte im
deutschsprachigen raum verhindert oder
von ausschreitungen begleitet worden
wird immer länger
in zürich wurde im theaterhaus
gessnerallee auch der auftritt des afg
vordenkers und philosophen marx jungen
vereitelt diverse veranstalter luden den
australischen philosophen peter singer
aus nachdem behindertenverbände gegen
die einladung protestiert hatten
mit der begründung seine äußerungen
entsprechen nicht dem humanistisch
emanzipatorischen selbstverständnis der
veranstaltungen empörte kundschaft
brachte den grossverteiler migros dazu
bestimmt der schaumküsse wegen des
rassismus vorwurfs aus den regalen zu
nehmen
der satiriker andreas thiel ist seit
seinen äußerungen über den koran bei den
meisten kulturschaffenden persona non
grata ein geächteter dem die bühne
genommen ist cancel culture ist unsere
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit in gefahr
sehen wir einen wiedereinzug des vor
modernen prangers
oder erleben wir gerade demokratie in
reinform weil bisher ungehörte stimmen
endlich ihre rechte einfordern oder wird
die kanzel culture massiv übertrieben
und ist nicht mehr als ein rhetorisches
manöver konservativer kräfte also bloß
ein phantom
ja die cancelled ein phantom oder das
eigentliche drama unserer zeit das
diskutieren wir jetzt und zwar mit
unseren gästen bei uns sind franziska
schutzbach sie ist soziologin und
geschlechterforscherin an der
universität basel und ich habe dieses
buch geschrieben die rhetorik der
rechten und bei uns zu gast ist ijoma
mangold er ist literaturkritiker bei der
zeit und philosoph und auch er hat ein
buch zum thema geschrieben der innere
stammtisch ein politisches tagebuch ganz
herzlich willkommen
es ist ja so kanzel coach muss im moment
für vieles herhalten vieles wird als
cancelled stadt bezeichnet wenn wir uns
darauf einigen dass es im kern darum
geht dass personen die eine unliebsame
aussage machen massiv kritisiert werden
attackiert werden vielleicht sogar ihren
job verlieren dann sagen sie solche
fälle mag es geben von einer canceln
culture von einer kultur des kämpfens
kam dennoch nicht die rede sein
also ganz richtig ich sehe kein tzl
fälle ich würde auch nicht behaupten
dass es das nicht gibt cancel fälle
ich frage mich allerdings wirklich ob
man eben von einer kultur des kämpfens
sprechen kann und vor allem frage ich
mich inwiefern ich mir total
verschiedenen maßstäben gesprochen wird
also welche beispiele denn dann
herangezogen werden um eine solche
kultur zu beweisen wenn er mich zum
beispiel wie vor kurzem wieder die
gleichstellung in basel gekürzt und
abgeschafft werden soll oder gegen die
gender studies vorstöße eingereicht
werden oder prominente feministinnen
sozusagen so viele hassbotschaften
bekommen dass sie sich zurückziehen oder
migrantische politiker sich zurückziehen
weil sie so viel hass bekommen dann gibt
es in der regel keine folge tom männer
die dann einen ausführlichen text über
cancel culture schreiben sondern mir
fällt einfach auf dass dieser begriff
sehr stark dann in eine rolle spielt
wenn es eben um sogenannte minderheiten
anbieten gibt also da zieht man dann
ganz viele beispiel heran
die beweisen sollen dass minderheiten
jetzt angeblich zu gefährlichen tätern
geworden sind aber das will ja erst
einmal einfach heißen der begriff wird
sozusagen nur für das eine phänomen
verwendet nur wenn die eine seite
attackiert wird aber nicht dass es diese
kanzel culture nicht gibt ja das könnte
man dann je nach dem wenn man so quasi
den begriff ausdehnen würde es könnte
man vielleicht noch mal anders
diskutieren aber ich finde eben er wird
gilt im moment zumindest aus meiner
sicht eben sehr stark dann benutzt wenn
eben vor allem auch sehr oft
privilegierte menschen die sich
eigentlich immer überall äußern können
oder sehr oft äußern konnten
so quasi auch ein stück weit ihre
privilegierten positionen verteidigen um
ja und eben abwehren die kritik von
massow in die kritik von vor allem
minderheiten abwehren dann kommt auf
diese also aus meiner beobachtung heraus
dass der begriff mangold frau schutzbach
nennt hier schon schlüsselbegriffe da
geht es um privilegien da geht es um die
frage wer eigentlich täter und opfer ist
es geht um die frage ob diese
einzelfälle ein gesamtes ergeben wenn es
sich wie frau schutzbach andeutet um ein
reines gespenst um ein rhetorisches
gespenst handeln sollte ist es doch ein
ziemlich lebendiges gespenst der zeit
oder ja ich muss auch immer schmunzeln
wenn gesagt wird wenn jede woche wieder
gesagt wird aber cancellara ist nur ein
gespenst ist nur ein phantom
das ist ein sehr lebendiges phantom ich
würde auch sagen um der analytischen
reinheit willen gewissermaßen ist es
sinnvoll so ein begriff möglichst selbst
kreativ zu verwenden obwohl er natürlich
ein politischer kampfbegriff ist das ist
unvermeidlich alles namentlich anderem
stammtisch werden wir aus jedem begriff
ein kampfbegriff machen das auch gut so
aber werden den versuchen möglichst
deskriptiv zu fassen dann will ich auch
sagen natürlich gibt es dieses phänomen
auf beiden seiten des politischen
spektrums denn erst mal ist es eine
anthropologische konstante dass es
menschen schwer erträglich finden dass
andere andere meinungen haben und hört
es äußert sich oft in dem wunsch dass
der andere einfach verschwinden möge ja
dann gibt verschiedene formen des
verschwindens und ich finde die muss man
vielleicht auch alle einzelnen benennen
ich würde zum beispiel sagen dass so was
wie körperliche bedrohung anders denken
als die grenze culture von rechts
die findet quasi nicht in diesem
diskursiven rahmen statt den wir
diskutieren wenn wir über linke
cancelled versprechen linke geld kein zu
kalt oder geht das immer eher um so eine
kulturelle hegemonie also um den versuch
man nennt das in der szene auch die
plattformen also leute der meinung man
von den der meinung man meinung ist die
sei nicht auf der höhe der moral der
gegenwart die sollen erst gar keine
bühne bekommen das ist glaube ich immer
der kern der vorstellung und dann würde
ich aber schon noch sagen es geht
darüber hinaus ich finde die plattformen
schon ein problem und zwar weil es dumm
macht das ist ja das problem
das problem an der kanzel culture ist ja
gar nicht so sehr auf meine vielleicht
hat für den einzelnen der dann kein
auftritt hat mag dass er durch sein aber
wir begeben uns als gesellschaft eine
chance uns nämlich mit leuten die dinge
sehr anders sehen als man selber
austauschen zu müssen
das ist doch eine tolle herausforderung
das ist ja das argument von jon stewart
mit dem liberalen strophen des 19
jahrhunderts der gesagt hat wir werden
zu einer stromlinienförmigen sehr simpel
denkenden gesellschaft wenn wir es nicht
aushalten dass es andere meinungen gibt
aber das wäre ja glaube ich nicht das
problem was sie jetzt irgendwie
kritisieren würden oder frau schutzbach
sondern es geht darum dass sie sagen man
nennt etwas cancel kauzer ungewisse
stimmen wiederum eigentlich mundtot zu
machen und behauptet die hätten wiederum
mundtot gemacht das ist eigentlich ein
gegenseitiges in die schuhe schieben der
schulden stück weit
ja ich bin zu alt interessant weil ich
ich bin eigentlich der meinung dass
jetzt gerade in den letzten zehn jahren
auch durch das internet natürlich extrem
viele verschiedene stimmen die sie jetzt
so schön auch hervorheben jetzt erst
sichtbar geworden sind ja die waren eben
gerade vorher oftmals nicht da sondern
jetzt sind ganz viele zum beispiel mit
stimmen von minderheiten die man vor
zehn jahren noch überhaupt nicht gehört
hat oder nicht zur kenntnis genommen hat
sind jetzt eigentlich sichtbar geworden
hörbar sie sind eben auch nicht mehr
darauf angewiesen dass sie in so
genannten leitmedien überhaupt
eingeladen werden sondern sie können
über twitter über blocking über eigene
medien über eigene kanäle quasi auch
ihre anliegen formulieren
das ist ja passiert das passiert boxen
da und jetzt plötzlich habe die damalige
schutz canceln
jetzt ist das wird das als cancel
problem wahrgenommen doch schon quasi
die einfalt da ist das halte ich für
politischen kitsch kämpfe culture in
ihrer reinsten und durchschlagen form
haben wir an den eliteuniversitäten der
amerikanischen ostküste
das heißt kämpfen carter ist vor allem
ein eliten phänomen von universitäten wo
sie vermutlich 50.000 dollar im jahr
müssen bezahlen
in diesem campus milieu ist diese sind
dieser politischen reinheit
vorstellungen so stark geworden dass
kommt aus dem akademischen es kommt aus
dem universitären bereich dass die dann
immer im namen irgendwelcher
minderheiten sprechen ist schon klar das
ist ein konzept aber die durch sätze
oder die die diesen ton setzen sind
keine minderheiten sondern das ist das
aber das cockpit seh' ich ja das
herumtoben bewegungen ausbleibt life
center heraus aus allen möglichen
bewegungen heraus die uni ist ja nicht
irgendwie ein raum in dem keine also die
total abgetrennt ist von der
gesellschaft den eindruck habe ich meine
aber ich versteh ich verstehe gar nichts
weil das ist ein verwirrendes phänomen
erst mal geht es offenbar darum dass
eine vielfalt gepriesen wird
es gibt neue stimmen im raum und die
erzeugen natürlich auch neue kontraste
andererseits schnürt diese vielfalt dann
auf eine sandkasten logik zusammen du
bist blöd du bist auch blöd du hast
angefangen nee du hast angefangen die
sich dann mit rechts und links vermengt
und das zweite sagten sie haben mein
gott ist dass es irgendwie gar nicht
unklar ist ob das ein eliten phänomen
ist dass sich in diesen elitären kreisen
selbst findet oder wie frau schutzbach
das anregt eine soziale vielfalt von
unten nach oben abspielt das heißt es
ist doch unglaublich schwierig erst mal
zu begreifen welche dynamiken hinter
diesem phänomen cancelled verstehen und
meine frage wäre ist nicht eigentlich
der beste ansatz zu sagen die plattform
in welchen medien findet es statt cancer
culture ist ein digitales mobilisierungs
phänomen das ohne soziale netzwerke
nicht so genannt seien sie heute und
auch gar nicht existieren würde
nein aber es schlägt auf die kohlenstoff
welt durch selbstverständlich es der
shit storm ein phänomen des erst im
digitalen raum seine enorme dynamik
entfalten kann
aber wenn die macht von twitter
irgendwann so stark ist dass und das ist
in den usa der fall das ist nicht in
deutschland der fall
chefredakteure von der new york times
und so weiter einknicken und ihre
redakteure entlassen
dann haben sie natürlich kein keine
firewall mehr zwischen social media und
und dem analogen alltag
ja das macht doch doch ein unterschied
also wir würden ja wahrscheinlich sagen
es gab ja immer schon den versuch
personen die meinung vertreten die nicht
passen mundtot zu machen man hat
personen verbrannt auf scheiterhaufen
dann hat sie ins exil geschickt man hat
sie ausgeschlossen für vogelfrei erklärt
was es alles gab
aber es scheint doch ein unterschied zu
geben zwischen dem was wir kämpfen
können und dem was damals passiert ist
aber das ist finde ich ja so interessant
die leute die sagen kenzler culture gibt
es nicht die sagen gleichzeitig es gab
es schon immer und das finde ich eine
sehr unbefriedigende position und
zusagen gecancelt wurde schon immer dass
es irgendwie zu sagen castingshows sind
nichts neues weil auch paola und kurt
felix schon gecastet wurden ja die
wurden auch irgendwie selektiert aber
mit anderen dynamiken anderen effekten
anderen energien und die energien die in
der cancer culture frei werden das sind
mob hafte zusammenballungen die im
internet geschwindigkeit und macht
simulieren um auf einzelne personen mit
schädigungsabsicht zuzugehen
ja aber es gibt auch sehr viele legitime
kritik in diesen chats storms also
sozusagen dann auch eine form wenn
jemand eine position vertritt die zum
beispiel sehr viele menschen angenommen
ja zum beispiel rassistisch verletzt
dann gibt es darauf eine heftige kritik
die eben auch seine legitimität hat und
natürlich gibt es grenzüberschreitungen
von angriffsarten und formen die ich
absolut kritisieren würde und die die
nicht gehen also jemanden dann
sexistisch zu belästigen oder sogar mit
dem tod zu bedrohen logisch geht das
nicht aber wir müssen doch unterscheiden
was ist denn also reden wir von einer
illegitimen pranger kultur und wo ist es
einfach legitime kritik die man eben
auch aushalten muss gerade wenn man so
eine große öffentliche figur ist die
daneben ja auch wirklich starke
positionen vertritt das machen ja viele
da müssen sie doch damit rechnen dass
die dann der antwort darauf kommt die je
nach dem eben auch ziemlich heftig
ausfällt
harte kritik was unterscheidet das vom
schätzt der illegitim ist das würde mich
interessieren und vielleicht noch mal zu
den unis ich kenne jetzt nicht diese
ganzen fälle im einzelnen und da gibt es
eben wie gesagt das sind sicher auch
sachen
offen die nicht gut sind aber
einzelfälle sondern hier geht es um das
stromlinienförmige atmosphäre
ja aber dagegen aber genau diese kultur
ich halte dieses dauernde herbeireden
einer kultur tatsächlich auch ein
bisschen den verschwörungstheoretikern
zugang weil einfach die ganze zeit
einzelne beispiele gesammelt werden
an diesem beispiel da werden aber dann
auch immer nur halbwahrheiten erzählt um
das argument der kanzel culture machen
zu können
also da wird sehr oft halbwahrheiten
argumentiert und immer nur die beispiele
gesammelt die dann wiederum die eine
these bestätigen also sind sehr
verschwörungs ähnliche zugänge die da
gemacht werden weiß und um einige
weniger elitär ist wenn viel mehr leute
mitreden was an einer ungefähr ist und
wir sehen sind krass elitäre seine
gesellschaftliche selektion die man sich
hier gar nicht vorstellen genau an
diesen selektions gesellschaften feiert
grenze culture und identitätspolitik und
diversity programmatik fröhliche urständ
ja und werner müller ein bekannter
politologe der 1
weil er schon hat in princeton der hat
kürzlich auch in einer zeitung ganz klar
gesagt für ihn ist dass sendung in
aufgeblasen das gäbe es so gar nicht
erst recht nicht zum beispiel in
deutschland und da kann man jetzt lange
darüber streiten aber ich würde schon
gerne hier an diesem tisch darüber reden
was bei uns passiert weil das ist ja
sowas typisches dass man die griffe
nimmt aus den usa und die 13 1 überträgt
und das haben sie jetzt auch
herausgestrichen dass sie gesagt haben
das eine sind die campus phänomenen usa
das gibt es bei uns so aber nicht das
haben sie neulich gesagt ich bin um ihre
meinung über cancel kauzer hier sprechen
weil das wird ja dauernd gesagt werden
hier cancel couch für sein usa gibt es
eine buchstäbliche grenze culture wo
indem sie einen köpfe rollen also leuten
hier jobs verlieren
das gibt es in deutschland überhaupt
nicht im gegenteil habe ich sowas gefühl
in den großen medien wenn sie
gewissermaßen gegen bestimmte identitäts
politische glaubenswahrheiten oder ein
bestimmtes gepflegtes vokabular
verstoßen sieht es im zweifelsfall der
chefredakteur mit großem wohlwollen
weil der ja auch ein problem hat nämlich
dass seine belegschaft viel zu
einheitlich denkt und das ist natürlich
am ende immer tödlich für medien und für
ca
rettungen und insofern hat man
eigentlich eine gute eine gute position
war die nische wider den stachel zu
löcken nutzt und das hat in deutschland
keine konsequenzen mangold verstehst du
dich nicht mit schuh lage im
journalismus und geradezu eine
marktlücke die die cancelled schafft die
mutigen voran die brauchen wir auch
absolut weil im linken milieu wird immer
gern von diversity gesprochen aber die
tatsächliche meinungsbörse ti finde ich
manchmal erstaunlich abend sehe ich also
erstaunlich einseitig um trotzdem möchte
ich dann von anderen fällen finden
müssen auch über andere fälle sprechen
und passen es nicht ins konzept zeitung
oder aber inwiefern sie denn da denken
wir einen titel nur ein kabarettist der
kabarettist ein fernseh kabarettist bei
dem dann immer sehr sehr ausführlich
betont wird wie schlecht seine witze
sein und hoffentlich ist damit gemeint
wenn witze sehr schlecht sind dann darf
man sich schon auch mal verbieten
die dfg die deutsche
forschungsgesellschaft hat irgendein
jubiläum und zu diesem jubiläum hat sie
kronzeugen sucht seinen onlineauftritt
also berühmtheiten irgendwelche
prominenten die dann irgendein satz sein
sollten warum wissenschaft und forschung
so wichtig ist unter anderem fragten sie
weil er natürlich große bekanntheitsgrad
hat fragt sich auch dieter nuhr weil
dieter nuhr aber einige witze über kreta
thunberg und damit über freies for
future und damit über die frage des
klimawandels gemacht hatte galt er in
bestimmten milieus als klimaleugner was
er bestreitet spielt auch keine rolle
dass stellungnahme so groß dass die dfg
in ihrer erbärmlichen rückgratlosigkeit
ihn wieder um netz genommen hat
daraufhin man natürlich der gegen
schützte um so groß dass die definiere
erneuten verbindlichen rückgratlosigkeit
wieder drauf gestellt hat und da denke
ich mir ja da haben wir nun kursiert
schon rein kunden ein haben die mich
warum die nicht weinen
jetzt müssen wir mal überlegen wer wurde
hier genau gekämpft und dieter nuhr mit
sicherheit nicht das gleiche beispiel
gilt für lisa ecker es gibt viele
solcher messen dem argument dass die st
danach sind die noch bekannter daher
komme genau diese aber nennt sich ziehen
das finde ich ihnen
kann sich mal vor sie den alstom los
treten nee ich finde dass man ganz klar
sagen kann die dfg hat mit sicherheit
einen fehler gemacht
auf ein sternchen so zu reagieren war
das wurde ja auch hinlänglich bekannt
mittlerweile es gab ein paar vielleicht
keine ahnung paar dutzend leute die sich
aufgeregt haben über die video und die
dfg hatte angst und hat es runter
genommen das ist schlechte kommunikation
mittlerweile hat die dfg auch einen
kommunikations beauftragten eingestellt
für solche fragen die unis sind wir
nicht am geschicktesten mit solchen
problemen umzugehen das zeigt auch die
nervosität in diesem ganzen kontext
woher kommt die nervosität ja darüber
können wir gleich noch sprechen ich mir
sicher sein dass ihre nervosität gibt
ist die sache über die wir über die wir
sprechen wir zuerst noch über dieter
nuhr gesprochen und ich glaube es ist
falsch zu sagen dieter nuhr wurde
gecancelt weit da würde ich wirklich
gerne noch mal festhalten
es ist nämlich gar nicht so einfach
wirklich celebrities berühmtheiten zu
canceln weil die haben immer irgendwie
publikum es gibt auch ganz viele leute
die finden dieter nuhr jetzt erst recht
wir haben ja gott sei dank ich bin auch
mit dieser unterscheidung zwischen
amerika und europa nicht ganz glücklich
weil es eben eine globale mit ja das
wäre gibt und globaler personen die als
globaler adressiert werden und ein
bekannter fall den wir uns vielleicht
mal genauer anschauen könnten weil an
ihm sehr vieles sichtbar wird ist der
fall der harry potter autorin jk rowling
die in einen globalen shitstorm geraten
ist der meine kinder leserinnen und
leser weltweit in eine darstellungsform
zwang die vielleicht doch sehr
problematisch war barbara oder ja genau
und ich glaube es wirklich wichtig dass
wir hier den wortlaut ganz genau uns
anschauen weil das ich auch so bei
diesen fällen es kommt wirklich auf die
worte darauf an wie oft sehen informiert
über die fälle glaube ich sprechen und
caroline hat reagiert letzten sommer das
haben wir alle mitgekriegt in einem
tweet auf einen zeitungsbericht in den
zeitungs bericht war die rede von
menstruieren den menschen und sie hat
darauf geschrieben ich bin mir sicher
wir haben ein wort dafür kann mir jemand
helfen und meinte damit natürlich frau
und darauf wurde
rowling kritisiert sie legte dann mit
drei tweets nach und schrieb das
biologische geschlecht sei ein faktum
außerdem schrieb sie auch noch ich kenne
um liebe traums menschen aber auf
geschlecht zu löschen hindert viele
menschen sinnvoll über ihr leben zu
sprechen
daraufhin gab es trotzdem ganz viele
transaktionen und trans aktivisten die
verlangt haben sie zu canceln ihre
bücher nicht weiter zu verlegen nicht
mehr zu kaufen sie nicht mehr auftreten
zu lassen und so weit ich ihre bücher
verbrannt habe auf großen scheiterhaufen
frau schutzbach ist diese form von
kritik jetzt zum beispiel diese form von
kennt nicht das gerechtfertigt also nein
diese art von extremen dogmatischen
vorgehensweisen halte ich natürlich
nicht für besonders produkte also
konstruktiv aber ich finde schon dass
ist dass es dann wiederum vergessen geht
das quasi diese leute die da so
fundamentalistisch vorgehen das ist ein
teil von solchen aktivistinnen es gibt
aber auch ganz viele die ganz anders
vorgehen die eine sehr differenzierte
kritik an den aussagen von rowling auch
formuliert haben die auch ernst genommen
werden müssen die dann also man redet er
dann überhaupt gar nicht mehr über ihn
über über die inhaltliche problematik
von rowlings aussagen in dem sie quasi
der ganze fokus auf diese vermeintlich
jetzt so mächtig gewordenen minderheiten
gelegt wird und die quasi als total ist
drohszenario im erscheinen obwohl er
auch irgendwie die reale situation von
trans menschen und gerade die ist dass
dies eine der verlässlichsten gruppen
ist die eigentlich eben sehr oft
umgebracht werden und so davon hier
selbst schon darüber näher von
bayerischen minderheiten im islam reden
sie das sind hollywood-stars die nicht
mehr über eine verfilmung von harry
potter mit man sich distanzieren davon
dass sie wie heißt der emma watson ist
ein weltstar
sie bekommen dann natürlich auch nicht
schritt gehalten sie versuchen die immer
in so eine rolle zu bringen als sein des
bedauerns würdig schwache menschen
diesen wortbruch
nein das ist schon das system das ist
schon die macht man kann das mit ihrem
heiß gemacht aber es geht sind ja
minderheiten frage um die es geht da
geht es um ganz legitime wichtige frage
fragen zum beispiel wollen wir inclusive
sprechen sind wir bereit als
gesellschaft uns zu bemühen um menschen
die in wirklich mindern
sind und in dem sinne auch wirklich
diskriminiert werden das ist ein fakt
und wollen wir uns um die bemühen und
das wird mit diesem ganzen culture
argument absolut abgewehrt mit dem
cancellara culture argument wird völlig
abgewehrt dass es eigentlich um ganz
legitim kritiken gate an jay kay rowling
die sich nicht bemühen will inklusive zu
sprechen dann würde ich sagen forscher
jetzt muss marc oliver klein hacken die
die deutung ich bin mir inhaltlich
einfach stand aber die deutung des
phänomens die scheint mir realistisch
weil sie hatten in ihrem ansatz gesagt
ja da wird dann die kessel culture ins
spiel gebracht und dann wird gar nicht
mehr darüber geredet wie es trans
menschen gibt ich würde sagen der
falsche rowling beweist das gegenteil
da wurde eine globale ikone der jugend
ausgesucht um sie gezielt zu
skandalisieren auf einer lächerlich
schmalen basis wozu um aktivisten und
aktivistinnen in die situation zu
bringen über ihr thema zu sprechen und
genau das ist geschehen ich kann ihnen
bei meinen töchtern die teenager sind
sagen die finger auf einmal an sich für
die trans thematik und problematik zu
interessieren wurden dafür
sensibilisiert was ich sagen will ist
genau das gegenteil ist geschehen
dadurch dass man jake wollen zum mittel
eines zwecks erklärt hat zynisch nicht
fair
unfair ist den aktivistinnen in diesem
bereich gelungen was ihnen sonst nicht
gelungen wäre nämlich dass über das
thema gesprochen wurde und das ist ein
phänomen das cancel katar erklärt da
werden menschen aufmerksamkeit
ökonomisch als mittel zu einem
aktivistischen zweck gemacht und zwar
mit sehr hohen biografischen preisen die
damit einhergehende den blick darauf
werfen überzeugen
ich würde aber schon noch hinzufügen es
ist jetzt nicht einfach nur im sinne
zweck heiligt die mittel
soll ich würde auch sagen es muss gerade
in einer gesellschaftspolitischen
diskussion wo wir wo die frage nach
kindern offen sich ist zentral geworden
ist muss es schon auch möglich sein dass
man die vorstellung eines biologischen
geschlechts verteidigt ohne dass man
deswegen des scheiterhaufens würdig ist
selbst in
sie werden sich mit der thematik auch
besser auskennen ist man natürlich
unironisch selbst wenn die erdrückende
mehrheit der sozialwissenschaftler der
meinung ist das geschlecht gar nichts
mit biologie zu tun hat sondern eine
reine soziale konstruktion ist so glaube
ich doch immer noch dass wir in einer
pluralistischen liberalen gesellschaft
es aushalten sollten dass jemand wie
jacky rowland
ich glaube geschlecht hat auch eine
biologische wurzeln findet dass kein
skandal finden nicht wenn man diesen
satz sagt dass man schon automatisch auf
der böse täterseite ist die trans
personen ausgrenzen möchte aber ich weiß
nicht ob das wirklich in dem fall
abgebildet wird es bei uns seid ihr eine
geschichte da muss herrliche thrice alle
hintereinander angucken und es geht
natürlich um diese idee dass da
beleidigende aussagen gemacht worden
sind jetzt kann man fragen wer darf
überhaupt darüber sprechen oder
definieren was eigentlich sagen jetzt
mal objektive kriterien für beleidigt
zeit sind zum beispiel
man kann über alle diese dinge sprechen
und die finde ich auch wichtig diese
diskussionen aber es scheint mir
irgendwie noch einmal um diese sache
auch zu gehen die wolfram vorhin
angesprochen hat nämlich man macht
jemanden zu mittel zum zweck um seine
agenda r fortzusetzen
und wir sprechen jetzt immer so aus
während das irgendwelche leute da
draußen die das tun
es gibt einen interessanten ansatz der
nennt sich moreau grant standing in der
philosophie im moment hoch diskutiert
und da ist die these wir alle tun das
ständig und das hat zu tun mit dem
internet wie alle licon dauernd oder
retweeten dinge die nur darauf angelegt
sind zu sagen guck mal wie weit ich bin
guck mal wie toll ich bin
guck mal ich hab sehr liegt und in
diesem kiez werden andere leute
niedergedrückt und das ist doch
eigentlich eine total unsicher also
manchmal würde ich gerne auch über unser
verhalten einfach sprechen
da sind wir alle daran beteiligt bin ich
absolut sicher also diese form von
gratis aktivismus und gratis mut mit
einem like sich zu solidarisieren mit
gruppe für die man lebensweltlich wenig
tut das ist sicher ein phänomen und das
andere das kann ich nur als netz
benutzer und der als person die manchmal
im netz angegriffen wird sagen da
unterscheidet sich links und rechts
leider überhaupt nicht die niedertracht
das schmähen
das bedürfnis auf jemanden der schon am
boden liegt dann auch noch mal digital
rhein zu treten
das ist etwas was sich jenseits von
links und rechts bewegt und es ist
natürlich der kern der cancer katja war
es wirklich an die niedrigsten instinkte
unseres sozialen da seine phrasierung
die eingefordert wird
ja aber man muss ja auch sehen dass
sozusagen die realen machtverhältnisse
gerade auch in zeiten jetzt ist er
abgewählt aber eben von donald trump und
anderen sich nach rechts verschiedenen
machtverhältnissen die alles andere als
irgendeine form von trans freundlicher
politik hervor haben und schon gar nicht
eine frauen- oder feminismus freundliche
politik wo abtreibungsgesetze wieder
rückgängig gemacht wenn in diesen zeiten
dann sozusagen auch die pranger kultur
so so so sehr man sie hassen mag auch
vielleicht ein mittel ist um quasi dann
neben diesen tendenzen die eigenen
belange stark zumal legitimiert zum
beispiel sagen sie herr staeck mit
debatte hat ja auch sexismus dass da ja
quasi das internet absolut wichtig weil
diese frauen dann an die öffentlichkeit
sind und die öffentlichkeit ist nicht
das beste mit ist es leider oft das
letzte mal so viele politische kämpfe
strukturelle versuche dinge zu ändern
zum beispiel in unternehmen
anlaufstellen einzuführen wo sich frauen
belästigt werden hinwenden können das
alles nicht funktioniert hat und dann
ist quasi dieser öffentlichkeit pranger
anklagen das mittel das noch bleibt ja
aber der pension ist das einfach auch
muss man einfach auch mal die realen
machtverhältnisse weltweit wo ich finde
wir reden hier als ob wirklich als auch
wirklich die diese transall transgender
an anliegen zum beispiel schon alle fast
erreicht wären und jetzt nur noch diese
blöden aktivisten zur fundamentalistisch
vorgeht es stimmt ja die ist genau das
gegenteil wir erleben politische
verhältnisse in denen zum beispiel auch
in der europäischen union mit sehr
vielen christ fundamentalistischen
bündnissen die da jetzt wirklich
systematisch daran arbeiten dass eben
anti gender politik
gemacht wird dass bestimmte
errungenschaften eigentlich wieder
zurückgedreht werden
das ist doch die ausgangslage teile da
ihre wirklichkeit beschreibung nicht ich
würde sagen wir haben es vermutlich sehr
unterschieden gesellschaft in räumen zu
tun wenn sie die usa und tram ansprechen
dann teilt sich das land natürlich
gewissermaßen in die flyer states die
parameter feld haben und dann die beiden
küsten haben die völlig anders
ausgerichtet sind und ich gebe zu wenig
über so ein phänomen nachdenken gehe ich
immer von meiner lebenswelt aus und in
meiner lebenswelt gibt es so einseitig
lebe ich nun mal in ein so schlechtes in
einer so geschlossenen blase gibt es zum
beispiel eine trump anhänger
das heißt ich hab die wirklich beobachte
beruflich privat usw ist eine in der ich
sagen würde
die machtverhältnisse wie sie sie still
dann sehen eigentlich umgekehrt aus ich
würde im gegenteil sagen und das gefällt
mir da nicht wir leben seit 56 jahren
sehr stark in einem öffentlichen diskurs
bei dem der kulturell hegemonial und die
meinungshoheit hat der ein möglichst
hohen opferstatus für sich beanspruchen
kann
sie sprechen die ganze zeit von den
minderheiten als während das
gewissermaßen die schwächsten der
schwachen
ich glaube wir leben längst in einer
ganz anderen gesellschaft wo die wo es
einen gibt der vierten begriff der der
opfer olympiade der klingt erst ein
bisschen zynisch beschreibt aber sehr
viele prozess in der öffentlichkeit
ziemlich genau
je mehr gewissermaßen die sich zu
rechnen können eine kollektive gruppe
die historisch gesehen als opfergruppe
dargestellt wird desto stärker ist ihre
stimme desto glaubwürdiger und dann
heißt es immer wenn jemand anderer
meinung ist er möglicherweise weiß und
alt ist und männlich oder ein zizmann
ist was heute sogar eines schlimmstes
schlimm ist dann heißt es lasst doch mal
erst die betroffenen zu wort kommen wer
nicht selber betroffen ist kann
überhaupt nicht mit drehen und das finde
ich auch wieder so ein moment der
diskurs verarmen weil es immer schade
ist wenn jemand nicht mitreden kann aber
herr mangold wird zu sagen also die
geste zu sagen lassen wir die
betroffenen auch zu wort kommen das
scheint ja nun auch medial zunächst mal
eine gute idee zu sein und das passiert
in der sozialen selektion die die
meisten redaktionen auch ihrer zeitung
haben eben nicht weil man dafür
hintergründe haben es die diese menschen
die diesen prozessen reisen
gar nicht erreichen was mich aber noch
in diesem zusammenhang interessiert wird
es ist ja ein mediales phänomen und wir
müssen über journalisten und angst in
journalisten reden und da ist der
implizite zensor das ist meine eigene
wahrnehmung und auch die wahrnehmung der
menschen mit denen ich arbeite in den
fünf letzten 50 jahren hat sich in einer
weise verändert verschoben in der man
vorsichtig wird in der man in gewisse
prozesse nicht mehr eingreift in der man
sich fragt muss ich mir dieses thema
noch zumuten was bedeutet es wenn ich in
diese talkshow gehe habe ich die
nächsten drei tage dann mit irrationalen
unflätigkeiten aus dem netz zu tun wenn
ich jetzt frau bleisch frage frau
bleisch gibt es denn frauen und sie wird
darauf antworten ist sie schon in der
schleife dass sie fragt wie wird das in
metz skandalisiert und diese innere
implizite zensur die einreist ist das
eigene geschichte an diesem problem
sondern wir nicht mehr nachdenken mehr
nachdenken finde ich auch gut und ich
setze mich auch nicht in der talkshow wo
es um keine ahnung um die anatomie von
zebras geht weil ich mich damit nicht
auseinander gesetzt habe und bei
gewissen dingen würde ich auch sagen es
sonst erst mal die person sprechen die
das erlebt haben die eine ahnung davon
haben aber und da finde ich hast du
vollkommen recht
ich finde schon problematisch wenn die
alle beginnen angst zu haben vor
gewissen themen und nicht mehr mit
diskutieren und das hat wiederum etwas
damit zu tun wie wir eben deswegen sage
ich immer wieder müssen bei uns anfangen
wie wir miteinander umgehen und da
glaube ich nicht dass es links gibt oder
rechts gibt dass diejenigen oder die
anderen mehr skandalisieren sondern es
ist ein phänomen das uns alle angeht und
wo ich eben auch denken wäre ohne das
internet wäre es so weit nicht gekommen
ohne diese sozialen medien wo man anonym
übereinander her fahren kann wo man die
ganzen mops organisieren kann und sie
haben vor in den pranger als positiv
dargestellt als letztes mittel sozusagen
das kann ich verstehen
gleichzeitig finde ich den pranger
durchaus hoch problematisch weil es
natürlich auch eine form von lynchjustiz
ist man liefert die leute aus es gibt
kein richtiges gericht
es gibt keine möglichkeit auf berufung
es gibt kein strafmaß das gerecht wäre
es ist auch nicht klar wann man dann die
dieses jahr dagegen traf justin sowas
beste ist ich sage das ist oft eben ein
letztes mittel das heißt vieles davor
hat eben nicht
als notwehr meinen sie als eine von nur
ganz wichtig weil wenn wir in dieser
angst und skandalisierung schleife sind
es gab jetzt beispielsweise in der
sternstunde philosophie ein fall der
auch deswegen interessant war weil eine
gewisse schnitzel und standardisierungs
logik in den vordergrund trat bei einem
einstündigen gespräch hat der schweizer
schriftsteller adolf muschg über die
kanzel culture etwa nach 50 minuten
gesagt das sei für ihn eine form von
auschwitz und das ist eine viel
vergleich um eine sprachliche form der
gleichsetzung die denke ich unbedingt
und ohne einschränkung zurückzuweisen
ist und die auch in der öffentlichkeit
insbesondere auf twitter eine sehr sehr
sehr breite gegenseite bekommen hat
gleichzeitig handelt es sich ich will
das gar nicht wie schön ich denke das
ist so das ist wirklich eine leistung
die man markieren und jemand gegen man
sich wehren muss gleichzeitig war es ein
einstündiges gespräch und niemanden der
viele tausend menschen die sich auf
diesen einsatz gestürzt haben nicht nur
gestürzt haben weil sie den vergleich
falsch fanden sondern weil sie die
chance sahen vielleicht eine biografie
eine stimme die ihn aus verschiedenen
gründen ohnehin unliebsamen jetzt war
die gelegenheit das zu tun was ich
eigentlich sagen wir befinden uns alle
in einer situation in der ein satz wie
ich barbara einsatz den wir sagen
wirklich an den punkt kommt an dem
unsere karriere nicht nur stark
geschädigt sondern sogar zu ende ist
aber dass seine guten ich frage mich was
das natürlich entsprechend er hätte sich
doch entschuldigen können er hätte das
relativieren könnte sagen kann ja was
für ein scheiß vergleich es tut mir leid
das war einfach in der rage blöd
formuliert aber was macht er erhält ein
gibt ein ganzes interview danach wo er
die these nochmal ausführt und nochmal
bestätigt also wo man dann einfach sagen
muss ja gut dann meint er ist wirklich
so und dann ist wirklich vielleicht eine
person die jetzt wiederholt diese
holocaust oder auschwitz vergleiche
macht ja also vielleicht müssen wir dann
hatte ich mit anderen leuten über diese
probleme reden als jetzt mit jemandem
der im
auschwitz vergleich gemacht weil er hat
ja wiederholt und das meine ich auch bei
jay kay rowling sie hätte ja auch
hinsetzen können sagen okay vielleicht
muss ich mir mal anhören was denn jetzt
da die argumente sind und mal irgendwie
überlegen und und ernst nehmen
stattdessen volle pulle effektiv dagegen
halten ich habe recht ja also ich finde
dass das wäre für mich auch die frage
warum können wir denn nicht uns
hinstellen und sagen ja ok ich muss dann
vielleicht noch mal überlegen weil das
wild schon akzeptiert also dass man sich
lohnen und relativiert was heißt
entschuldigen oder noch mal nachdenken
oder sagen ja ich muss nochmal über das
wird akzeptiert was akzeptiert wird ist
das strategische zurück kriechen dass
einem die pr beauftragten der jeweiligen
schauspieler der mit jahren sagen okay
du hast dich hier so damit wir
wenigstens unseren frieden haben was da
an überzeugung ist es völlig wurscht
denn das ist einfach nur ein spiel von
beschuldigung pranger abgesang
das hat mit überzeugung extrem wenig zu
tun
und die gefahr ist ja und da kommen wir
auf eine these zurück die sie schon
erwähnt haben und die möchte ich
unbedingt noch diskutieren
das führt dazu dass wir diesen diese
verengung haben des sogenannten
meinungs- korridors also dass ich ja
immer wieder das was gesagt wird wenn es
um cancel culture geht die alle trauern
gewisse die mir nicht mehr zu sagen es
wird alles immer eng es gibt diesen
diese verengung des meinungsforschers
undeutlich gerne mal ein paar beispiele
weil ich hab mich mal hinsetzen überlegt
was gibt's denn dafür beispiele wir sind
lauter eigentlich andere beispiele im
sinn gekommen
zum beispiel als ich ein kind war war
völlig klar man aus dass auf den tisch
kommt es gab vielleicht einzelne
vegetarier aber es gab sie kaum
heute ist essen etwas womit man sich
definitiv in den fetten absetzen kann
und essen hat viel zu tun mit identität
nun kann man doch nicht sagen dass
deswegen der meinungs- korridor enger
geworden ist sondern im gegenteil es
gibt eine vielfalt von meinungen über
essen für die ein riesenskandal fleisch
zu essen
für die anderen ist es ein skandal
veganer zu sein also ich habe das gefühl
es gibt eigentlich in vielen bereichen
sehr viel mehr meinungen und genau das
führt zu friktionen genau das führt zu
streit also ist die these richtig einer
verengung des meinungsforschers ist es
nicht so wir haben viel mehr meinung
deswegen streiten so sehr wir sitzen am
tisch und alle reden mit und das heißt
eben dass manche auch die halt woher
meinungen die alles unwidersprochen oder
so gehalten jetzt plötzlich infrage
gestellt sind
ich finde ich empfehle es ganz stark
sodass eben viel mehr meinungen gibt
alles auch noch zu meiner kindheit oder
eben viel mehr verschiedene mögliche
positionen zu verschiedenen themen und
das führt natürlich dazu dass dann
gerungen wird wer wer ist stärker um
sich da irgendwie gehör und und
legitimität zu verschaffen und ein
mittel um die andere meinung abzuwehren
ist zubehör ist cancel kalter zu
behaupten ich möchte gerne mal hören
herr mangold das sieht bei suez am
anfang hat gesagt haben dieses leben das
wiso rückschau den jahren 71 hat er noch
so richtige damals sagte man alt 68er zu
den lehrer die auch schon linken habitus
pflegten und ich bin selber überhaupt
kein linker wie man hört aber eines hat
mich an den typen immer begeistert dass
die sich so ungerne an spielregeln
hielten dass die so ein diebisches
vergnügen hatten alles anders zu machen
als es vorgeschrieben war
und deshalb war für mich immer zumindest
unter gewissermaßen so habituellen
gesichtspunkt das was für mich so links
war wenn da steht das springen vom
beckenrand ist verboten dann musste man
als linker unbedingt vom beckenrand ins
wasser springen
was heute die millennials die wolken
millennials über die wir im grunde reden
wenn wir über die trägerschicht von
cancelled zu sprechen was die für ein
leben führt ist ein völlig anderes das
ist eines wo alles reglementiert werden
soll wo eine ungeheure angst herrscht
dass ein falsch gewählt das wort zur
retraumatisierung bei irgendwelchen
menschen führen könne
deshalb ist wichtiger ist um eine mikro
aggression zu vermeiden dass wir uns
alle einigen auf eine bestimmte rede
fromm und das finde ich zum aus zwei
gründen langweilig langweilig weil
einheitlichkeit immer intellektuell
unfruchtbar ist und ich glaube auch ist
es eine überschätzung der symbolischen
ordnung es ist ja kein zufall dass in
dem zeitpunkt wo gewissermaßen
tourismus in seiner realen struktur
übermächtig wird diese neue linke nur
noch über symbolpolitische themen
verhandelt und dabei das finde ich das
erstaunlichste überhaupt nicht merkt
dass sie dies in unmittelbarer allianz
mit dem konzern des kapitalismus tun es
gibt kein keine keine gesellschaftliche
kooperation die mehr diese diversity
programmen ich denke gerade adidas
adidas hat personal personalvorständen
weil es den namen nicht vor einem jahr
ausgebrochen weil sie sagt bei adidas
gelb ist kein rassismus problem
man würde erstmal so denken wenn die
personalvorstände ist und findet er es
gibt eine rassismus problem bei adidas
ja dann sollte sie gehen also ich will
sagen dieses gesamte dieser gesamte
identitäts politische ausrichtung der
diskurse wird er vom kapitalismus über
nagasaki bei mir in ihrem spiel weil sie
der legitime und gar nichts zentrale
gerechtigkeit ansprüche die wir im
grundgesetz und in der verfassung ja
auch stehen haben wenn es darum gehen
soll dass mehr menschen mit reden dass
es inklusion geht das es gleichstellung
gibt dann heißt das auch eine
kindergerechte sprache natürlich nicht
nur aber das seien zum beispiel ein ganz
zentraler teil des wegs receive sprechen
ist das ist dass der notwendige folge
dessen was in der verfassung steht das
wäre mir jetzt in jeder weise normal
kann das natürlich aus ist gut ihn aber
die tatsächliche herstellung von
gleichstellung stets in der schweiz in
der verfassung in deutschland im
grundgesetz das heißt aber es ist kein
finaler schritt zu sagen das ist doch
mal eine kindergerechte strand damit
müsste man ja das muss man sie ist okay
jetzt mal aus der forschung wissen wir
dass zum beispiel gender gerechtes
sprache tatsächlich bewirkt bei mädchen
wenn auch ärztinnen genannt werden dass
sie dann auch frauen im kopf haben wenn
ich aber nur ärzte sagt dann haben sie
nur männer klopfen reproduziert sich ein
bestimmtes das ist nur eine kleiner
seiten diskus was ich worum es mir geht
das jetzt hier wirklich auch
gerechtigkeit forderungen legitimiert
wird werden mit diesem brisanten
abwerten von snowflakes oder
empfindlichkeit generationen
sie beschreiben mich gut dass sozusagen
da eine aversion auch besteht die die
gerechtigkeit wirklich umzusetzen die
natürlich bedeutet dass leute weg also
platz machen müssen für andere
umverteilungen heißt zb bei der quote
wenn wir mehr frauen in den pott
parlament haben dann können darf weniger
männer seien ja das ist umverteilung das
ist nicht kämpfen das ist umverteilung
das ist gerechtigkeit und um diese
sachen was ist das jetzt nennen aber
konstatiert was mir doch keiner kenne
das jetzt ein strohmann denen sie
aufbauen das canceln ist doch ne
strategie innerhalb eines der campus was
steht um die allgemeinen gerechtigkeit
forderungen jetzt im moment diskutiert
werden unter anderem gleiche
vertretungen in parlamenten aber nur
etwa wird verlieren wir wirklich das
phänomen vielleicht aus den augen aber
es war es interessant dass sie gesagt
haben dass nennt er keine kenntnis bach
würde ja wahrscheinlich auch farben in
den wenigsten fällen gibt es wirklich
kennst und das ist ja gerade die
diskussionen aber für arbeit machen
werde
ich werde über die runden ein bisschen
haben sie mich überzeugt mit dem was sie
vorhatten da meinten sie
dieter nuhr kann man ist kämpfen denn
danach ich finde ja auch was mich am
meisten nervt ist snowflake sie nannten
es war ja diese dünnhäutigkeit und ist
rum die kamera dann vielleicht sagen wir
ja zur cancel culture wir nehmen sie in
kauf weil wir kämpferisch genug sind uns
davon nicht entmutigen zu lassen und
sind umgekehrt aber auch nicht bereit
diese hermann reeh moralisierung des
diskurses zu folgen vielleicht wäre das
viel schöner werk einzeln will soll es
mal probieren
ich nehme den chips torn gewissermaßen
und kaufte lasse mich umgekehrt aber
auch nicht auf eine moralisierung eines
eigenen diskurses verpflichten in dem
ich dann beim falschen bord wie du voran
sagt es reumütig zu kreuze kriechen und
sage ich werde nie wieder sagen menschen
die menstruieren wir nennen sie frauen
oder so ich glaube vielleicht sollte man
einfach mehr robustheit entwickeln
vielleicht nenne das die löse aber ist
das nicht ein angebot das man annehmen
kann weil eines ist ja auch klar dieser
inneren zensor wie ich in form
beschrieben habe er ist auch eine innere
sensibilisierung die ich an mir selber
auch spüren natürlich denke ich mehr im
programm leitungstätigkeit darüber nach
ihr genug frauen sind wir die fans
natürlich denke ich in meiner themen war
war ist das zu selbstverständlich
gedacht ist das für ein anderes thema
also ich will damit sagen dieser inneren
zensor sein
die valentes phänomen und frau
schutzbach sagte das ja auch es gibt ja
ne benennbar fortschritt in unseren
köpfen der muss vielleicht auch ich
komme hier sehr entgegen mit angst erst
mal etabliert werden da muss erstmal
einer schleife in gang
damit man so denkt was heißt ja da und
wagen sich aber die angst aber sicher
daran liegen und nach gerechtigkeit oder
von von inklusive gesellschaft die
anliegen von minderheiten wurden zu
allen historischen zeiten immer als
übertrieben anmaßend und illegitim
bezeichnet immer das passiert es gerade
wieder und ich möchte einfach machen
auch daran erinnern woher diese rhetorik
der opfer der verweichlichung der
empfindlichkeit der sentimentalität wir
haben das alles bei gab es bei hitler
bei den ganzen nazis otto weininger die
geschrieben haben
das sind antisemitische
verschwörungstheorien
diese idee die aber rasch die sprache
jetzt da es nicht mein leben der linke
ist dass wir eine reihe hat fantasien
moral idealen folgen deren gegenseite
dann gar nicht mehr unterhalb von
goebbels und hitler nein ich glaube das
ist gewiss haben auf der seite auf der
einen seite wo die gender studies stehen
und die leute die bücher von jk rowling
verbrennt ist alles schon gut aber es
muss irgendwie möglich sein zu sagen die
leute die auf der anderen seite stehen
sind noch nicht girls oder hitler da
gibts doch riesige valentin aber ich
möchte eben diese historische
kontinuität das so quasi eine aversion
gegen das schwächliche verweichlichte
terminisiert eine sehr starke
argumentation war von rechts meistens
von rechts um legitime anliegen von
minderheiten abzuwehren also das können
wir aber historischen struktur das
gängige twitter schimming gegenüber
leute gecancelt werden ist die sollen
sich mal nicht so haben die sollen wir
nicht so empfindlich sein
also ich wäre sehr vorsichtig diese
rhetorische figur einseitig zu verorten
und ehrlich gesagt auch gerade im
kontext von musik es ist immer sehr
schwierig mit der total keule des
nationalsozialismus zu kommen und
content pure dynamik
wir versuchen an die schulen sollen an
diesem tisch vielleicht doch ein
bisschen einheit und frieden
herzustellen indem ich vielleicht noch
eine figur gerne einbringen würde
nämlich das sogenannte top kill paradox
obwohl nämlich wirklich glaube genau das
sehen wir heute wieder die idee bei
tocqueville war dass er gesagt hat zu
dieser art von diskurs kommt es eher
wenn wir mehr gleichheit haben sobald
mehr gleichheit hergestellt ist wie
jetzt das was an ungleichheit noch
vorhanden ist es noch sehr viel stoff
oder empfunden und plötzlich beginnen
diese streitereien und deswegen würde
ich sagen ist doch eigentlich großartig
dass wir uns zu streiten
was sagt das der philosoph philipp übel
wenn ich ihn richtig wiedergeben
weiß gleich wo genau ich das 40 beim
gelesen habe real das kann man nachher
geht in zahlen statistiken geht
rassismus zurück der effekt ist
natürlich das dann aber umgekehrt die
empfindsamkeit für rassistische micro
aktion nennen das meist technischen
begriff zunimmt so dass tatsächlich das
subjektive gefühl ist die ganze
gesellschaft ist so tief rassistisch wie
noch nie und und die leute wagen eben
eher an diesem diskurs teilzunehmen es
ist nicht einfach nur noch der
voith-chef mit seinem freund chef der
darüber diskutiert was geht und was
nicht sondern ist neben all diesen
diskurs teil
und weil wir vorher nochmal über den
meinungs- korridor sprechen haben sie ja
sozusagen gesagt stimmt überhaupt nicht
es gibt keine ausweitung des korridors
sondern es gibt eigentlich sehr viel
mehr immer noch diese verengung haben
dann aber gleichzeitig die blasenbildung
erwähnt und ich glaube dass ich ja das
drama es mag schon eine verengung geben
dass meinungs- korridors aber es gibt
mehr blasen also ich würde sagen das
problem ist wir sind in unseren mini
diskursen sehr eng aber es gibt viele
parallelen
solche diskurse und die schlagen einer
anderen auf dem kopf barbara in dieser
frage wo eigentlich die kanzlei wird
implizit oder explizit ist die blase der
wissenschaft der universitäten ja eine
besonders interessante blase nun wissen
wir soziologisch und auch von der partei
identifikation dass das eine sehr
ungünstige blase ist sagen wir mal um
usa 80 zu 20
rechts und links einmal 116 116
wissenschaften kommt auf einen moderaten
world und die frage ist ja auch ist das
wissenschaftssystem ist die forschung
selbst es gibt ja jetzt gruppen netzwerk
wissenschaftsfreiheit diese gegründet
haben in deutschland wie in der schweiz
die genau sagen
es gibt eine art linke programmatische
hegemonie die zu schweigen und auch zu
forschungs tabus führt gegen die man
sich merken muss weil es nämlich sozial
unglaublich unwichtig ist was in den
geisteswissenschaften insbesondere sich
an den universitäten zeigt vielleicht
auch noch mal ein beispiel einwerfen
dass mich schon noch beschäftigt hat die
politologin elham manea eine anerkannte
politikwissenschaftler uni zürich
die hat sich eingesetzt für burka verbot
und wurde mit morddrohungen konfrontiert
da kann man sich ja schon fragen kritik
in ehren kritik ist in ordnung
morddrohungen gehen meiner meinung nach
nicht
und sie hat genau das dann zum ausdruck
gebracht dass sie gesagt hat eigentlich
ist die wissenschaftsfreiheit die
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit an der
universität in gefahr
wir sehen es gibt da unwuchten teilweise
sichtbarer und teilweise unsichtbare art
wir haben aber glaub ich auch insofern
einen konsens gefunden als übereinkommen
dass die cancelled war eigentlich ein
fortschritt in tome ist ein
emanzipations symptom wir werden für die
differenzen hellhöriger weil schon sehr
viel erreicht es meine beiden letzte
frage an sie beide wäre in diesem sinne
sollten wir die cancelled als etwas
sehen was ein übergangsphänomen ist und
insofern auslaufen lassen
das also beobachten oder aktiv bekämpfen
als etwas was wirklich die
meinungsfreiheit gefährdet also an sich
bei uns überraschen dass ich glaube kein
falsches über das problem der kanzel
culture die mich wütend gemacht hat ist
eines der fünf profil vor drei jahren
als nämlich gewesenes identitäts
politische lager so selbstherrlich
regiert
dass alle diese verlautbarungen nie in
frage stellen wollen
und das hat sich gedreht im letzten jahr
total gedreht und das meer will ich gar
nicht ich will eigentlich immer nur das
sieht dass die gegenposition auch
hinterfragt werden dass man nicht so wie
in der kirche einfach nur nicht und weiß
man kriegt sonst zu viel ärger wenn man
eine position in frage stellt und der
punkt ist erreicht die die identitäts
politische seite die kehrseite man sie
aber lassen wir den perfekten
die politische seite ist mittlerweile
und einem rechtfertigungsdruck und das
ist wichtig das will ich von mir ist
will ich das mutig ihn zu dass noten sie
mir zu und darüber bin ich glücklich und
sowieso was schlimme sind doch nur diese
phrasen
es gab es eine zeit lang hieß das zu 1
das ist body shaping das ist / aiming
das ist rassismus das ist ddr 20
das ist meinungsdiktatur das waren ja
alles nur phrasen aber die leute trugen
diese blogger phrasen im brustton einer
großen politischen moralischen
aufrichtigkeit vor und warten sie noch
nicht klar dass ihn nichts anderes macht
als phrasen haben solche these
überraschend cancel culture is over frau
schutzbach mit der bitte um eine kurze
antwort oder fängt es gerade produktiv
erst an
ja ich habe schon das gefühl dass es
jetzt auch produktiv werden könnte weil
also eben auch innerhalb von identitäts
politischen menschen ist es ja nicht so
dass alle einheitlich wären sondern es
gibt ja auch sehr differenzierte auch
problematisierung von identitätspolitik
die gibt es aber schon seit 50 jahren
die wurden jetzt noch nie gehört weil
immer gleich nur so ein bestimmtes ja so
ein schreckgespenst von einer bestimmten
art von identitätspolitik quasi auf
gemacht wurde und ich denke jetzt kommt
geht es darum zu differenzieren und die
ganzen wichtigen forschungen und stimmen
die es dazu ja wirklich geht die super
interessant sind gar drittes baby debug
hat schon in den 80ern sehr stark die
die ja die gefahr dass selbst
veräußerung darüber geschrieben eine
marxistischer theoretiker das ist ja
alles da wir beide müssen das eigentlich
nicht neu erfinden das ist da und das
muss jetzt endlich mal in der
differenzierten variante diskutiert
werden ich sehe eine überraschende
einigkeit wir treten in eine neue
hoffentlich produktiver gefahr in der
erkundung der vielstimmigkeit die unsere
gesellschaft ausmacht die wird immer
streit mit sich bringen so wie wir heute
gesehen haben
vielen dank franziska schutzbach und
ijoma mangold für ihre wahl
der vielen dank fürs interesse auch
ihnen zu hause nächste woche spreche ich
mit richard david precht über den
begriff der pflicht und darüber warum
wir sie brauchen wenn es mit unserer
gemeinschaft und gesellschaft voran
gehen soll
ich freue mich wenn ich wieder dabei
sind eine gute woche bis bald
[Applaus]